good morning
happy sabbath to all of you
it's a tremendous privilege for me to be
here
for this special
celebration better life television
was established i understand in 1990
that would make better life television
22 years old
now if time lingers that means that
better life television is still in its
youngest years
and the best is still to come
i was getting caught up a little bit on
the
history
of better life television
it's a story of one miracle after
another
it's just amazing the way the lord works
you know one thing that really impresses
me when i attend
the asi national convention
which is held in different places
is to see
the number of ministries that are
represented there it's just amazing
you know they usually have this large
area where the ministries have their
booths
there are hundreds
if not thousands of booths
of ministries that have sprung up
to try
and finish god's work on earth
it is so encouraging to see that
you know that's really the most
inspiring thing for me at asi is to have
the opportunity of going and visiting
with people who
have those booths and uh who have
different ministries
i love the theme that was chosen
for this year
preach
the word
is there anything else to preach
i don't think so
before we study god's word i would like
to invite you to bow your heads with me
as we pray
our father and our god what a joy it is
to be here this morning
no better place on earth to be
then in your house of worship
to render you the honor and glory that
you deserve
and to hear your voice speaking to us
through the ministry of the holy spirit
we ask father that that spirit that
inspired scripture will be with us to
instruct us
and we thank you father for the
privilege of approaching your throne in
prayer
thank you for hearing
our plea
for we ask it in jesus name
amen
i invite you to open your bibles with me
to the book of hebrews
chapter 11.
hebrews chapter 11. we're not talking
about bankruptcy here
chapter 11
we're talking about hebrews chapter 11.
you're slow this morning
hebrews chapter 11 is known as the
chapter of faith
because the word faith is used
at least 25 times
in this one chapter of the book of
hebrews
however the word faith is not the only
critically important word in this
chapter
there are five other concepts
that are linked with the word faith
that form a cluster of concepts
and so what i would like to do in the
time that we have to study
is to take a look at this cluster of six
ideas that are linked together
in hebrews chapter 11.
now of course the first concept is the
concept of
faith
and we'll have a lot to say about faith
in the next few minutes
now linked with the idea of faith
is
god's
word
because basically faith means trusting
what god says
it means trusting god's promises
it means
believing
god exactly for what he says in other
words there is no such thing as faith
without
the word of god
in fact in hebrews chapter 11 we find
this concept of faith linked with the
word several times
for example we're told in hebrews 11 and
verse 3
that the worlds
were framed
by the word of god
we find
in hebrews chapter 11 and verse 7
that noah was divinely
warned
about the coming of the flood god spoke
to him and of course
noah responded in faith
in hebrews chapter 11 verse 8
we find that god
called abraham out
god spoke to abraham
and of course abraham responded in faith
in hebrews chapter 11 and verse 11
we find that god promised sarah
that she would have a child in her old
age
and sarah believed the word of god
in verse 13 we find that abraham and
sarah and enoch and abel and noah all
died without having received the
promises see the promises once again the
word of god
and in hebrews 11 verses 17 and 18
we find that god had promised abraham
that he was going to have a son from his
own loins
and that son would be the son of the
promise
and so time and again in hebrews chapter
11 we find the idea of god speaking god
warning god promising
god saying
in other words
faith is always linked
with
god's word faith means believing and
trusting god's word implicitly what
implicitly what god speaks
we
are
to believe
without
question
now there's a third concept in the book
of hebrews chapter 11 in this cluster of
ideas
we also have
a very strange paradox
in this chapter
the strange paradox is
that
people
can actually
see
what is invisible
now what does the word invisible mean
the word invisible simply means that you
can't see it but in hebrews 11 several
times we find the idea that people who
have faith
can see
what cannot be seen
they can see the invisible believe it or
not and you say well where does the
bible where does hebrews 11 say that
well it's actually found in several
verses in chapter 11.
it's found for example in hebrews 11
verse 1 the very beginning of the
chapter it says faith is the evidence of
things
not
seen
and then of course we have hebrews 11
and verse 3 where we're told that the
things that are seen were made out of
things that are not seen things that do
not appear
in hebrews 11 and verse 7 we find god
speaking to noah
and it says that he was warned of things
not yet seen
noah was warned of things not yet seen
but noah could see the flood
before it rained
because when god said it's going to rain
noah didn't have to see the rain to
believe it he knew that the flood was
going to come
he saw
what was invisible to his eyes at that
very moment
and then of course we're told about
moses in verse 27
it says there that moses when he decided
to go out of egypt instead of becoming
the next pharaoh
we're told that he was sustained
as one
seeing the invisible
now that's an interesting paradox isn't
it seeing the what
seeing the invisible you say now what
wait a minute invisible means you can't
see it but faith allows you to see
what you can't see with your simple
eyesight
it kind of reminds me a little bit about
the story of an individual in scripture
that we've all heard about
we have an expression these days that we
use we say
that an individual who doesn't have much
faith is a doubting thomas
the reason why we say that is because of
course thomas was
an individual who had a very interesting
philosophy his philosophy was to see is
to believe
when the disciples said we have seen the
lord
thomas said
unless i can see it
i won't believe.
well about a week later jesus appeared
to the disciples in the upper room once
again and thomas was present
and so jesus said to thomas okay thomas
put your finger here in my hands
put your finger in my side and see that
it is i
and the bible says that thomas fell at
the feet of the jesus and he said my
lord and my god
and then jesus said something very
interesting which is in harmony with
what we've noticed in hebrews chapter 3
chapter 11
jesus said because you have seen
you have believed
blessed are those who have not seen
and yet believed
in other words faith allows us to see
things which have not materialized yet
faith helps us see things that have not
taken place
faith helps us to see future reality as
if it was taking place today if it as if
it was taking place now
now there's a fourth element in the
cluster
this cluster of faith so to speak
and that is
that faith
is always
active
faith is always dynamic
is always doing something
in other words god speaks
you believe that what god says is true
even though you can't see it
and then you decide to act on the basis
of what god's word says
faith is an action word
that's why james said that faith without
works is what
faith without works is dead in fact if
you notice that the list of heroes
in hebrews 11
you'll discover
that every single one of them was doing
something
see faith
is not simply believing something in our
head
faith means believing what god says
accepting god's challenge accepting
god's warning and doing something about
it
acting on god's word
that is true
dynamic
faith
but there's a fifth element
in this cluster of ideas in hebrews
chapter 11.
and that is
that faith makes possible
that which is humanly
impossible
time and again in this chapter you find
things taking place that are humanly
impossible
things that are
illogical
things that are unreasonable
things that are unscientific apparently
things that are absurd
you say how could these things ever
happen
because faith
is able to grasp
things that are illogical and
unreasonable humanly speaking
in other words faith allows
us to do through the power of god that
which is impossible and the reason why
we can do that which is impossible is
because for god nothing is impossible
for god all things are possible
we're only talking about impossibilities
from the perspective of human beings not
from the perspective of god
the sixth element in this cluster of
ideas that we find in hebrews chapter 11
is
that faith
always
is connected with
a reward
faith is always connected with the
reward
when we have faith
trusting in god's word
we act on that faith
even though everything appears to be
illogical and unreasonable
and as we see the potential even though
it's not actual right now
god ultimately rewards our faith by
fulfilling that which our faith focuses
on
are you understanding this point
in fact in hebrews chapter 11 and verse
it says
that god is the rewarder
of those
who diligently
seek him
no this faith is always rewarded
the object of your faith
is always rewarded
and in hebrews 11 and verse 26
we're told that moses looked
forward
to the reward
so we have this cluster of ideas
in hebrews chapter 11.
this cluster of ideas that that must go
always together they can never be
separated
faith
god's word
dynamic faith
faith doing the impossible
because for god nothing is impossible
seeing that which cannot be seen with
the naked eye
and ultimately
faith
being rewarded
now hebrews chapter 11 gives us the
definition of faith
don't think that faith is something
nebulous
something just that happens in your
brain something that you can't put your
finger on
faith is very tangible
you say now how is that well notice the
definition that is given of faith in
hebrews chapter 11. it says faith is the
substance
is is substance something that you can
that you can grasp a substance
yes is it concrete
yes faith is the substance see faith is
not just some ethereal idea faith has
substance it says faith is the substance
of things what
hope for so the things that you hope for
have they happened yet
if you're hoping for them no but does
faith have substance even though what
you're hoping for has not taken place
yet
absolutely faith is the substance of
things hoped for and that says it is the
evidence of things what
the evidence of things not seen in other
words faith is not wishful thinking like
saying oh i hope it will happen no
faith is substantial it's concrete it's
not abstract
now what i would like to do is i would
like to take some examples that we find
in hebrews chapter 11 that illustrate
these points
you know
better life television is a ministry of
faith
i know what it's like to establish a
ministry of faith
nine years ago we started an endeavor
to establish secrets unsealed i'll tell
you a little bit more about it a little
bit later on
we had nothing in our hands
no money no equipment
all we had
was a command from the lord to share the
gospel
and we decided that we would act on it
and the lord has done incredible things
but i'd like to take some examples first
of all from hebrews 11 itself
take for example noah
noah as mentioned in hebrews chapter 11
god told noah
noah
built a large
ship
on dry land
because it's going to rain
was that logical
was it scientific
did it make sense
it made no sense it's illogical
was it impossible
yes
humanly speaking
the great philosophers and scientists
said you're crazy
building a large ship on dry land it can
never happen
it's impossible
yet when god said to noah there's going
to be a flood
noah didn't have to have to wait for the
flood to come
for him the flood took place that very
day
because god said so
could noah see the future could he see
the invisible
yes he could
because for noah
the day that god warned him that there
was going to be going to be a flood he
didn't have to wait for the flood to
take place he believed god he knew that
there was going to be a flood the future
was then present so to speak
and so noah
decides
that he's going to act on his faith
god speaks
noah has faith
to do the impossible
and he decides to have a faith that what
that works
or did noah just simply sit down and say
lord
thank you for this great information i
believe you
how did he show that he believed
by acting
by taking out hammers and saws
and cutting down trees
and building the ark
in that way he showed that his faith was
real
that he really believed what god was
saying if he hadn't built an ark
people would say well how is it that you
believe that there's going to be a flood
but by building the ark he was showing
that he really believed what god had
said
so are all of the elements all all of
the cluster of ideas are they together
in the story of the flood
absolutely
god
speaks
noah responds in faith
even though he can't see the flood he
knows that he can take it to the bank
he worked upon his faith that was based
on god's holy word
even though it was impossible he knew
that for god all things were possible
let me ask you was his faith rewarded
when did he see the reward
when it started to rain and he and his
family were safe inside the ship
his faith was rewarded
so
can there be such a thing as faith
without god's holy word
absolutely not
in fact you know there's a text in
romans chapter 10 and verse 17 that says
faith comes by
hearing
and hearing by the
word of god
can there be such a thing as faith
without the word of god
so is it a dangerous deal to stand
behind the pulpit and not preach the
word
but preach human opinions
it's a very dangerous thing because
there's no basis for people to
responding in faith
the word must be preached it must be
god's word that is preached so that
people can respond in faith to god's
word
and then of course we have the story of
abraham
god says to abraham abraham
time to leave
had a nice lifestyle
in ur of the counties he was very well
to do
and god says
you've got to leave
and abraham might have asked him where
lord
i just leave i'll tell you later
wow
did abraham act on god's word when god
said leave
did he respond in faith
yes how did he respond in faith
by leaving
he took the step forward
he left
did what had got god had asked him to do
appear to be illogical
i mean canaan was full of a bunch of
barbarian tribes
it was a dangerous place to live back
then
have you ever read about the nations
that lived in canaan
and god says i'm going to give you the
whole land of canaan that'll look
ridiculous
and yet when god said i'm going to give
you the land abraham believed god
even though he had not seen the land you
see when god says it and we believe it
at that moment it's true
faith is the substance of things
hoped for the evidence of things that
you cannot see
at any given moment
and so abraham
left
just the way god said
was his faith rewarded
you know that it was
later on in the story of abraham you
have abraham offering his son isaac
or being willing to offer isaac
god had said to abraham abraham
isaac
is the seed from whom the seed will come
god had told abraham that
god had said you can take it to the bank
the seed the promised seed will come
from isaac
incidentally
did abraham have
some doubts about god giving him isaac
see even the father of faith sometimes
had a lack of faith
you know and his wife
that was a different story she laughed
how's this possible see it was
impossible
but you know what
they ultimately came to believe god and
they decided to have sexual relations
they acted on their faith
because this was not some virgin birth
they had to believe god enough to have
sexual relations
they acted on their faith
if you please their faith was dynamic
and they said we know even though it
looks ridiculous we know that god is
going to give us a son
from both of us
they knew it was true because god said
it they didn't have to wait for it to
take place
so abraham god says to abraham abraham
abraham
take your son the son of the promise
to a mountain that i will show you which
we know to be mount moriah
and offer him as a sacrifice there
did that appear to be logical
is that reasonable
it was absurd it was ridiculous
didn't make sense
and yet what did abraham do
he didn't even share the news with his
wife
because she was probably much more
sentimentally involved
and so basically the story tells us that
abraham got up early in the morning left
with isaac
said if god said it
even though it appears to be illogical
unreasonable if god spoke it
i respond in faith i'll do it
his faith was active
along with his work his faith was active
through his works according to james
chapter 2.
and so he goes to mount moriah
and you know how the story ends
the story ends by the angel holding back
the hand of abraham
and saying abraham abraham now i know
that you trust me
now i know that you have faith
and then we have the story of moses
do you know moses was in line to be the
next pharaoh of egypt
you're aware of that right
he was a great philosopher he was a
great a great military leader
he was a great historian i mean
moses was a multi-talented individual
and he was going to be the next pharaoh
of egypt
but god says to moses moses instead of
being the next pharaoh of egypt
you know and enjoying all the riches of
egypt and all of the fame and all the
power and the pyramids and in every all
of this that you can see before your
eyes
i want you to
leave egypt with the people that are
going to be critical and rebellious and
they're going to just make your life
miserable for 40 years
i want you to leave choose rather to go
out into the wilderness and take these
rebellious people to canaan
that's what god said
did moses have faith
how did he show his faith
i want you to notice i'm going to read
here from hebrews 11 beginning with
verse
hebrews 11 and beginning with verse 24
listen to this carefully
it says there
by faith moses
when he became of age refused to be
called the son of pharaoh's daughter
that was a big act of faith
because he was going to have the glory
of egypt verse 25
choosing rather to suffer affliction
with the people of god
than to enjoy the passing pleasures of
sin
esteeming the reproach of christ greater
riches than the treasures in egypt
for he looked to what
to the reward
by faith he forsook egypt not fearing
the wrath of the king and now notice how
interesting this is for he endured
as seen him who is
invis did moses see the invisible
he was sustained seeing the invisible
and so he left
egypt
with this rebellious people to go across
the desert to the promised land
what god had asked him to do appeared to
be absurd and ridiculous
it didn't make sense
and yet moses decided to obey god
let me ask you was his faith rewarded
where is moses today
where would moses be if he decided to
stay in egypt
he'd probably be a mummy
in the british museum
they have many many mummies
of egyptians there in the in the british
museum
but you see
the faith of moses was deeply rewarded
because moses even though he didn't
enter the earthly promised land he
entered the heavenly promised land
and later on he appeared to christ on
the mount of transfiguration
an amazing story
are you seeing how this cluster of ideas
all comes together
or you take
rahab let's take one final example
before i share some some interesting
things about
our ministry secrets unsealed you take
rahab
you know the the israelites were
gathered around this walled city jericho
humanly speaking could that city be
overcome and conquered
by a group of slaves
that had no military organization and
had no weapons they didn't know how to
fight
of course not
and yet rahab in the city received the
spies
and she said you know when the city is
destroyed not if she says when the
cities did she believe the word of god
when the city is destroyed could you
please
ask your god despair me and my family
what appeared impossible to her
happened
the city was destroyed
but her faith was
deeply rewarded
because she and her family
were saved from the destruction
now go with me just for a couple of
moments to a text that we find in ii
corinthians chapter 4
and verses 17 through 18. if i ask you
what is more real what you can see or
what you can't see what would your
answer be
yeah that's because you've already been
primed
[Laughter]
notice second corinthians chapter 4 and
verses 17 and 18.
you know some people can't believe
unless they see
but you know if you see you don't have
to believe
did you understand what i said
some people see to say to see is to
believe but if you can see it you don't
have to believe it
because you can see it
now notice ii corinthians chapter 4 and
verses 17 and 18.
for our light affliction
that's this life now by the way folks
which is but for what
and some people say a moment i've been
suffering all my life
yeah and what is your life in the
context of eternity
a moment
for our light affliction which is but
for a moment
is working for us
a far more exceeding and eternal weight
of glory
now notice this here's here's the
paradox
while we do not look
what do you look with
with your eyes right we do not look at
the things which are seen
but at the things which are not seen
isn't that doesn't that appear to be
kind of a contradiction
we don't look at what we see we look at
what we don't see
it sounds kind of ridiculous
but then he says for the things which
are seen are what
temporary do you know that includes our
houses do you know that includes our
money in the bank
do you know that that includes our
nice automobiles that we drive in
all of those things are temporary
the more we have the more the lord is
going to have to burn
this is not a time to be to be saving
for a rainy day that's what the people
did before the flood
this is a time to be investing in god's
cause
in the preaching of the word through
ministries like better life television
only in eternity folks will we know
the full extent of a ministry such as
this one
only an eternity and any
any funds that we place into this
ministry we are participating in the
work of winning souls for christ
and i won't guarantee it but maybe the
lord will put a piece of a star on your
crown
or maybe even a star
for participating in this very important
work of saving souls
now notice what he continues saying
well we do not look at the things which
are seen
but of the things which are not seen
for the things which are seen are
temporary
but the things which are not seen are
eternal what's more real what you can
see or what you can't see
well you can't see but that's difficult
for us who live in the 20th century 21st
century
because we live in a society where you
know things
seeing touching that's reality but you
can't see that's not reality
you know someone
when i when i mentioned that we need to
invest in the lord's cause
he said well you know i have a very nice
house i hate to give up my house
i said
is it made of gold
well i got a very nice car
does it fly
see nothing that we have in this earth
is as good as what we're going to have
there
i have not seen nor ear heard
nor entered the imagination of man the
things that god has prepared
for those who love
him when god speaks you can take it to
the bank
you know there's another promise in the
bible
jesus spoke it
let not your heart be troubled
you believe in god believe also in me
in my father's house are many mansions
if it were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you and if i
go to prepare a place for you i will
come again and receive you to myself
that where i am there you may be also
do you have to wait for jesus to come to
believe that
no
i don't have to
can we be absolutely certain that that's
true
absolutely
because when god says it you can take it
to the bank
guaranteed
go with me to romans chapter eight
verse 24
romans chapter 8 and verse 24 here the
apostle paul says something very
interesting
this is what he says
for we were saved in this hope
speaking about the hope of when this
mortal body will be transformed you know
when this creation comes to an end and
uh you know we receive our immortal
bodies that's the context
he says for we are saved in this hope
but now notice what he says but hope
that is seen
is not hope
are you grasping what is saints faith
he's saying
hope that is seen is not hope
for example
if i said this morning right in front of
you i said
i hope to be able to speak someday at
better life television camp meeting
what would you say
is this guy losing it or something
he's here
do i need hope
no
because i'm already here
so the apostle paul simply is saying
here in romans 8 verse 24 saying for we
are saved in this hope but hope that is
seen is not hope in other words if that
which you hope for is already here why
hope for it
he continues saying for why does one
steal hope for what he sees
we have hope that jesus is going to come
soon
that we're going to heaven for a
thousand years and then this planet
delivered from the virus of sin we're
going to live here forever and ever
we believe that you can take it to the
bank
we have this hope
that burns within our hearts but you
know what you don't have to wait till it
comes
we can be sure now because god says so
in his holy word
i believe that the world needs most more
than anything faith that's why jesus
said when the son of man comes
will he find faith in the earth
you know better life television
as well as many other ministries
are doing a tremendous work
to reach people where they can respond
in faith to god's word
i praise the lord every day for
ministries like better life television
uh three abn
and many others who are broadcasting
god's word
it's amazing you know
people would never open their doors but
you can sneak in through the television
you can reach people that you would
never reach
by knocking on doors and you can get in
through television
but it takes money to to
produce television programming to keep a
television station going
you know just uh
before i bring this to a close
about nine years
ago we decided to start secrets unsealed
it's a television production ministry
it's not a television
ministry like better life television but
we had nothing
but a vision
and a command from god
and we decided that we were would
respond in faith
we didn't just sit down and say the lord
reign money from heaven
we decided to share the vision
and soon many people embraced the vision
we had people in the church that said
they actually laughed in our face
they said where are you going to get 300
dollars to buy the cameras and the
switcher and all the equipment that you
need to produce
where do you think you're gonna get that
money
and i said from the lord
believe it or not within ten months
through the power of god we had raised
three hundred thousand dollars
to purchase all the equipment that we
needed and we've been producing with
that equipment for the last nine years
and it hasn't broken down
it's amazing
people said it was impossible
it appeared unreasonable
but we decided that we would step out in
faith
and the lord has has rewarded our faith
beyond our wildest expectations
you know
i know that we're supposed to see the
future by faith but i must be honest
that i never would have envisioned what
the lord has done with secrets unsealed
just
seeing where we're at today
this is
it defies human reason
no we just had the privilege of
purchasing a new facility
debt free
raised in two and a half years
not because of us
not for the glory of the people who
contributed but for the glory of the
lord because this is god's ministry
and as i hear testimonies wherever i go
of people that have that have come
to to an acceptance of god's precious
message for these last days the present
truth message of the seventh-day
adventist church you know it's just it
makes me tingle all over
i'm so excited to see the way that the
lord
has worked in such a marvelous way
in making it possible for us to take his
message to the world
life television
is a ministry that god has established
to broadcast the programming that is
produced like ministries like secrets
unsealed
and any investment that is made in this
ministry will
be translated into souls
souls that will shine forever in god's
kingdom as stars
throughout the ceaseless ages of
eternity
i pray that the lord will give us a
vision
a clear vision
to take
our resources
not only our money
our time
our talents
our strengths
yes and our resources
to invest
in better life television
because this is god's ministry
let us bow our
heads father heaven we thank you for
the awesome privilege of being here
we thank you because you have given us
your holy
infallible
trustworthy word
we thank you father that in this world
that is so confused
there is a certain guide
which is
the word
of the living god
i ask father that you will bless better
life television
and that you will impress the hearts of
those who are here
to make an investment in this ministry
so that many souls can be saved in your
kingdom
we thank you father for the privilege of
approaching your throne
we thank you for hearing
this the prayer of your people
because we ask it in jesus name
amen